you don't want to be in TV anyway and
this guy said well you don't want to
talk to me you want to be a Movie Maker
why don't you go next door you know
who's next door how would you like to
meet the greatest film director who ever
lived Jack Ford and I sat waiting for
John Ford to arrive and about 40 minutes
later this this old dude walks into the
room and he had kiss marks and she says
okay you've got five minutes probably
one and he sat me down and he just said
tell me you want to be a picture maker
I'd never heard that before but I never
forgot it and I said yeah I really do
what do you know about art kid and I I I
I did a stammering I wasn't expecting
that question see that painting over
there I said yeah he said we'll get up
and walk over to the first paint well
what's in it and I said well I see two
Indians on horses no where's the Horizon
and I said where the Horizon is the very
very bottom of the painting all right
get over here he said when you're able
to appreciate Wyatt to the top and why
it's at the bottom you might make a
pretty good picture maker now get the
out of here